clairement en montagne le vent aussi a
soufflé très fort météo france a noté
des rafales à 133 km heures cet après
midi à chastre et de quoi dissuader les
promeneurs et les vacanciers qui avaient
l'intention de chausser les skis
aujourd'hui
conséquence les stations auvergnates
étaient désertes comme ont pu le
constater au mont d'or régis cothias
eric texiles les vacances de noël
constitue un temps fort pour les
stations de sports d'hiver en cette fin
d'année c'est plutôt un temps mort le
vent viola empêche tout fonctionnement
des remontées mécaniques
résultat le mont-dore allard et super
besse où tout petit ralenti bref
quelques très rares s'enrager de la
glisse brave quand même une météo
exécrable
on est déçu mais bon j'ai demandé de se
rendre à quoi les gens là des pistes on
va en profiter si on vit en trois jours
on va pas rester à l'hôtel jouent aux
cartes 1 donc bon c'est bon on va faire
une petite bosse cancer 2 3 offre
quelques descentes et surtout des
remontées à pied ça réchauffe les
vacanciers veulent profiter de leur
séjour mais le courage et la témérité
pour affronter des conditions hostiles
ont quand même des limites
bon on va rentrer et on va rentrer chez
nous et puis se satisfaire
soit qu'on a chez nous c'est à dire bond
piscine des petits trucs comme ça mais
nous on avait prévu de faire du ski de
faire de la luge de fer de battes où
toutes les activités qu'on nous propose
à l'heure actuelle dans cette région
mais pour l'instant au moment on a c'est
foutu c'est foutu des vacanciers quelque
peu dépités des congés écourté faute de
stations enneigées et ou ensoleillé
restent les principales conséquences de
ce coup de vent les dégâts les plus
importants se limite à quelques arbres
décapité en bord de route
en l'absence de neige les chasse-neige
roule quand même et toujours pour
dégager les chaussées